you know you're born with a certain
thing here you know this kind of gut
feeling this kind of determination
you're born with it I try to make the
analogy of that some people are born
with a talent if you locked me in a room
with a piano teacher for example for one
year and no doubt at the end I could
perhaps knock out a rendition to roll
out the barrel maybe would I ever be a
concert pianist not in a million years
because in that example that person has
a talent and I think I was blessed with
some kind of talent of some kind you say
which which an eye for things a very
fast brain to see the end or at the end
conclusion normally the end conclusion
I'm very you know all very skeptical of
what can go wrong and that is something
that I'm afraid to say you can't go and
buy in a book somewhere or go and buy a
bottle of entrepreneur juice in boots or
something like that you either born with
it or not finally I want you to get over
this notion that I find so annoying that
so many people have that success and
power in life is dependent on something
like genetics like some people are born
with a larger brain or they have wealthy
parents who are able to send them to the
right school or or it's a lot a matter
of luck what really makes people
successful and powerful in life and it's
not just me saying this I read hundreds
of books on the subject what makes
people successful is their degree of
motivation ok I could repeat it a
hundred times but it's true every time I
say it when you are motivated when you
feel yourself emotionally engaged in the
subject you learn faster you learn what
could take somebody 10 years to learn
you can learn in two
years when you feel emotionally engaged
with something you're able to push past
ups all the obstacles the sense that
it's genetics or the size of our brain
or our parents money you can't control
any of that obviously and they could
become kind of crutches for some people
but the amount of motivation you feel
the emotional connection you have to
what you're studying or doing that is
something within your control that is
something you can choose to take and it
is you you're gonna find people giving
you all kinds of great advice about your
careers about where you should go if you
know for your MBA etc but if there's one
piece of advice that I think is more
important than that is that is it is
this idea of following this these
natural inclinations and creating your
own career path and finding a way to
engage those deepest motivating parts of
your psyche my intention with this video
was to spread understanding not fighting
I want you to see that it's not one
point of view or the other you can pull
and learn from both especially the one
that you don't immediately resonate with
embrace the genius of the end